pour le ser le mois de septembre c'est
le début de la saison des amours
alors pour faire des rencontres il donne
de la voix dans ton nom brame du cerf
qui les cris poussés par le cerf donc le
mal pour défier des autres serres est
aussi séduire les biches tous les ans à
cette période de l'année à savoir entre
mi septembre début octobre
c'est la période de reproduction de
l'espèce le cerf et durant cette période
d'à pousser ce cri fameux on appelle le
brame à s'il sait se faire remarquer des
biches il se montre plus timide avec
l'humain dans la forêt de rambouillet
c'est pas facile de les rencontrer à
cette époque de l'année vous avez les
entendre et l'avantagent à l'espace
rambouillet c'est que le dispositif
installé permet de les voir avec quasi
certitude
lors des visites que l'organisme
l'espace rambouillet propose des visites
en autonomie mais aussi des moments
spéciaux le matin ou le soir sur
réservation
et bien c'est très prisé effectivement
est là cette année on est pratiquement à
100 % de réservations
si les gens sont encore intéressés ils
peuvent venir y assister en journée en
toute liberté
ne reste plus qu'à penser à prendre sa
paire de jumelles et se montrer discret
pour peut-être apercevoir coup de foudre
entre cervidés